لجا اليها عدد كبير من النازحين وقد
استقروا بالقرب من هذه المنطقه على مدخل
منطقه المصدر هنا شرق مدينه دير البلح حيث
ايضا اصيب اعداد منهم اثناء الغاره
الاسرائيليه على هذا المنزل لعائله ابو
ركاب وادى الى اصابه اعداد من النازحين
الذين جاؤوا ليمكث هنا حسب ما طالبهم
الجيش الاسرائيلي بالذهاب الى منطقه جنوب
الوادي ستكون امنه ومن المناطق الخضراء
الساعه
810 اه شفنا الدنيا حمراء حمراء
ه المنطقه حمرا حمراء يعني لسه ما نمنا
ها عندي خمس بنات طلناه من تحت
الرد هذه مش حرب يا راجل اباده هذه هذه
عباده هذا ضربه محلي محلي هذا على صراح
الدين ما تخلي مصدر في ورايا نازحين
ناس ساكنه في خيم وفي جنبي هذا واحد من
ضرب الكاف
برضه ساكن جنبي جنب المحل ضربوا المحل س
الليله ودمروا المكان في شهيد من ضرب ركاب
بسمه صافر الله يرحم
مستشفى هذا منزل عائله بخي في مدينه دير
البلح والتي اغارت عليه الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه فجر هذا اليوم بعده صواريخ من
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وسوته
بالارض حسب شهود العيان هنا يتحدثون بان
بداخل هذا المنزل اعداد كبيره من
المواطنين الذين كانوا يجلسون امنين بدون
سابق انظار تم قصف هذا المنزل فضل الله
وكرم ربنا انه كل ليتنا طلعنا يعني حفظ
ربنا وسلام وامان الا الصبي الغلبان ذات
الاعاقه المخيم
المغازي نازحه غلبانه م لكن ذهبت ال ربها
هو افضل هنا يحاول المواطنين استخراج ما
تبقى من طحين واثاث من داخل المنزل كانوا
قد جاؤوا به في الايام الاخيره هنا في هذه
المنطقه التي تعد من المناطق الامنه في
جنوب دير البلح بطلع في الطحين وبنطلع في
الزيت ونطلع في الفراش وبنطلع في العفش
عفش البيت متبقي من العفش والله ايش متبقي
من العفش
المط حتى الاطفال هنا يحاول ان يبحث كل
منهم عن مقتنياته وعن ملابسه وعن العابه
هنا داخل هذا المنزل المتواضع في منطقه
البركه في جنوب دير
البلح هذا ما تبقى من بعض مقتنيات هذا
البيت الذي دمرته الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه يحاول هؤلاء الاطفال في هذه
الاوقات استخراج ما تبقى من العاب لهم
وذكريات من هذا المنزل الذي سوته الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه بالارض خلال الساعات
الماضيه جنوب دير البلح اشرف ابو عمره
الجزيره دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه